so what have we learned this week the
media sucks
yeah that's today's angle I speak of the
Covington story in which we realize once
again that the media will use anything
they can to destroy you and left
unchecked they won't stop if it wasn't
for other honest eyewitnesses the press
wouldn't have rested until the teens
were frog-marched into the La Brea Tar
Pits they embraced a video from a
sketchy source and pushed it out like
cheap meth instantly the teens became
this week's media approved evil and when
the media was caught pushing a lie they
blamed everyone but themselves but
thanks to NBC Savannah Guthrie we could
see media bias in all its glory
by comparing her questions of the
Covington team to the ones she asked
Native American Nathan Phillips you owe
anybody an apology do you see your own
fault
in any way first question how are you
doing do you think it was a good idea to
start chanting back at the protestors
has been a whirlwind few days for you
you find yourself on the front page of
every newspaper how are you doing and
how are you feeling did anyone say build
the wall you've certainly been through a
lot in these these last few days what
some people see is a young kid with a
smirk on his face do you think he should
have apologized do you think if you
weren't wearing that hat this might not
have happened have you feared for your
safety since all of this has happened
there's something aggressive about
standing there standing your ground talk
about a contrast reminds me of these two
[Applause]
I will not sleep tonight thanks to
Savannah I now know that standing still
is a sign of aggression now I wonder if
she thinks this is also aggressive it's
terrifying or how about this I don't
know how I feel about that or how about
this
well I guess I guess that is kind of
aggressive but watching the media
analyze the covington Fiasco it's like
watching a contestant judging her own
beauty pageant look it seems that I've
won again but as their preferred
narrative dissolves and they have no one
left to damn the story magically goes
away which is why you must always
remember this tale to remind you of
what's possible when the press the left
and social media are properly aligned
they will destroy you the same goes for
celebs there are liars and jerks
except for you Dean yes take down aunt
iris Cyrus you're okay Jo not yet
take these to Alyssa Milano and Kathy
Griffin two peas in a putrid pod
camouflaging their drooling hate with
fake compassion these two led the charge
and trashing the teens Milano branded
them racists Griffin wanted them doxed
so again why do we let fame excuse
people for being it I mean the plague is
famous and we don't admire that
yet these jerks count on their status to
excuse their own jerkiness but take away
their celebrity and they're just your
crazy neighbor in a soiled housecoat
muttering and sniffing their own fingers
the third culprit Twitter
it's a decency subtraction machine
replacing actual face-to-face contact
with bored malice it's a platform where
antagonism is its own reward and let's
not forget all of this was brought to
you by identity politics which dictates
the heroes and the villains always it's
a power struggle between oppressor and
oppressed and those roles are dictated
by the media academia and entertainment
complex white kids and red hats
oppressor low Native American oppressed
and those crackpot crackpot cultists who
initially accosted the t's they're just
delightfully eccentric with identity
politics the mob always rules as it
stalks a new victim every week the final
culprit your own eyes you can't trust
them anymore viral videos are designed
to trick them they're called viral for a
reason they're highly contagious and
they'll make you puke I initially fell
for the wrong version of events simply
by trusting my own beautiful blue eyes I
was fooled and I am never fooled I
ignored my own advice though which is
never rushed to judge true I was I was
at brunch at the time which is code for
I was super drunk but no excuses
bottle of Rose eh that's sad but if I
can fall for this crap then we can all
fall for this crap the best bet when
something like this shows up on social
media
run like hell to the safest space you
can find if only there was one place we
could run to and hide until this all
blows over in an era of volatile
political storms controversy can erupt
at any moment without warning the media
was quick to follow the students
involved racist when outrage strikes
will you have the facilities to keep
your family safe oh my god we have to
get downstairs before it's too late
why what's going on there's no time get
the kids to the outraged bunker
[Music]
[Music]
dad dad mom it's just Billy you have to
open the door quick we can't it's too
late if we open that door now we get
sucked into the outrage vortex zone now
can always have another yeah it was
hated Billy anyway you dragged us down
hey we could just weigh down the
outreach bunker it's for the best
the outraged bunker is impervious to
Wi-Fi hot cakes
self-righteous diatribes vilifying
generalizations stupefying story
developments and all other hot air that
comes with sensationalized breaking news
stories with the outraged bunker you and
your loved ones will be safe and healthy
so you can come out and enjoy life when
the dust settles as if that talk of the
town and reason happened well we made it
really
Holy Mother of God
what
so get outraged poker today warning
outraged hunters may provoke social
media withdrawals limited human
interaction new cycle apathy and an
increase in overall happiness
[Music]
[Applause]